[Musik]
ja ich komme gerade wieder von einem
gespräch mit dem bürgermeister der stadt
kiew mit vitali klitschko das immer an
verschiedenen geheimen orten hier
stattfinden muss in der stadt weil auch
er auf einer todesliste steht und wir
haben lange danach noch nach dem
interview über labor auf gesprochen und
er hat gesagt
wie ein mensch wie ein mann damit leben
kann
solche lügen zu verbreiten wenn kinder
sterben menschen sterben wenn ein
kinderkrankenhaus kaputt gebombt ist das
ginge nicht in seinen kopf und er hat
sich lange damit befasst heute genau so
wie ich auch und die frage gestellt wie
kann jemand mit so einer schuld leben am
ende auch ein außenminister der
wahrscheinlich momentan der zynische die
brutalste außenminister ist denn es gibt
auf der welt sehr gelassen ist ja jemand
der tatsächlich perfektes englisch
spricht er wurde immer groß gepriesen
auch von dem von vielen westlichen
diplomaten zumindest bis dahin als er
als die krim noch nicht überfallen wurde
also bis 2014 und viele diplomaten haben
von den tollen zigarren partys berichtet
die man mit sergej lawrow auf und dem
whisky dem man trinken könne und ich
frage mich und will das auch mal hier
zur diskussion stellen wie wird man so
hängt es allein an der abhängigkeit an
putin hat er angst dass wird er die
propaganda nicht mitmacht dass er dann
selbst ermordet wird oder was passiert
mit menschen die solche zynischen lügen
verbreiten also kommt für mich ist ja
gerade auch in mysterium muss ich sagen
auf der einen seite wirklich ein
erfahrener diplomat jemand der der bei
gesprächen dabei war wahrscheinlich wo
wir nur von träumen können und mit
leuten kontakt haben davon träumen
können auf der anderen seite jemand der
und zwar nicht erst seit jetzt sondern
seit jahren lügen erzählt die man sich
einfach nicht vorstellen kann also heute
haben wir das gehört mit es gibt keinen
krieg mehr dazu später aber seit jahren
sagt er
beispielsweise
immer wenn es in syrien giftgas anschlag
gegeben habe dass das waren die rebellen
haben um die giftgas gekommen und haben
sich dann selber vergiftet und wir wir
sind dann bloß die vorsichtigen wieder
versuchen zu helfen mit dem hermes hat
insofern särge labor für mich überhaupt
nicht verständlich auf der einen seite
ein intelligenter mensch mensch der
wirklich weißwasser sagt denkt man so
auf der anderen seite jemand der der
völlig im ideologisch in der
ideologischen babbel von herrn putin zu
leben scheint und wo man wenn man ihnen
sprechen hört nicht einfach nicht weiß
glaubt er was er sagt das ist wie so ein
tiefes psychoanalyse thema kubicki wir
sehen sie das glauben sie wer handelt
dann im auftrag gehandelt weil er weiß
dass will putin so also bleibe ich auch
dabei und verbreitet dass weiter oder
glaubt er dass am ende selbst
also ich bin auch gab es die analytiker
werde aber nicht ganz ich glaube nicht
dass er das selbst glaubt ich kenne da
brauch ich habe in moskau persönlich
schon getroffen weil er sieht behalten
was er sagt nicht wirklich glücklich
auch nicht wirklich überzeugend aus
momentan bewegt dass ich immer noch auf
der linie der russische propaganda das
ist hier ja nicht um einen krieg angeber
fall hat jetzt sondern eine
befreiungsaktion nach wie vor gibt es ja
aus dem kreml dieses märchen von den
nazis die ukraine regieren die es eigene
volk unterdrücken und das volk uns
befreit werden und mit jedem weiteren
tag ist krieg ist wird diese paradiese
offenkundig entlarvt und ich bin
wirklich gespannt wie lange auf die
kurve kriegen will wenn das alles nicht
mehr zu deutschland ist weil es
offenkundig geworden ist was gerade
passiert da könnt ihr aus dem ansteigen
der ist er der älteste ein außenminister
der welt ist sie 18 jahre lang als
außenminister das gab ihnen muss man
auch schon gerüchte über die nachfolge
könnte müsste sich das nicht mehr antun
ich vermute arbeit ist immer noch
versucht im kreml so wie ich ihn
einschätze er hört dann nicht zu den
falken sonst den tauben schlimmeres zu
verhindern denn noch einmal ich habe das
auf eine auslaufende fahrzeugen schon
gemerkt versuch zu erklären wenn man tut
ihnen in die ecke drängen dann wird es
problematisch
einer ihrer kollegen von der welt hat
mal eine geschichte erzählt die putin
immer wieder erzählt von einer ratte die
sie als kinder empfangen wollen die
hacker braucht die ganze im angriff
übergegangen ist dass er mehrfach
erzählt und deshalb sage ich noch einmal
nicht wir hatten tun uns selbst keinen
gefallen und in der zu installation
beitragen sie schon schlimm genug aber
wir müssen dokumentieren die grenze die
russen überschritten hat ist eine grenze
die dauerhaft oder jeweils über längere
zeit unser verhältnis
beschädigt habe weiter beschädigt und
wir können nur hoffen dass erst zu einem
vernünftigen gesprächen und seine
künftigen lösung kommen blickte noch
einmal jeden tag zu sehen wie menschen
stören die kinder stellen das in ihre
berichterstattung zu sehen das macht
einen auch möge das macht mich bürger
als seien sie ganz so rund
der fleischhauer das geht auch an sie da
gibt es unterschiedliche
herangehensweisen an eine vielleicht
lösung es ist also noch nicht alle für
alle menschen die im
religiösen raum bewandert sind ich
glaube wir sehen hier das böse ja das
ist so dass wir über putin da sehen wir
im gesicht von la france auch also wer
sich da hinstellt und sich letztlich
lustig macht über über tote kinder und
eben das ist ja ein satz der an
absurdität nicht zu überbieten ist wir
haben die kuh kranich überfallen wie für
keinen krieg
so die andere frage ja ich glaube dass
ich natürlich der westen gedanken machen
müssen das tut er auch starb dass die
amerikanische administration darüber
sehr genau nachdenkt
welche möglichkeiten man an putin auch
bieten kann
aus dieser ecke in dir sicher manövriert
hat wieder rauszukommen so war weil
darüber steht ja noch viele zeitungen es
gibt ja auch immer eskalationsstufen
also im konventionellen krieg
würde er möglicherweise sogar verlieren
gibt ja jetzt zunehmend auch
ernstzunehmende generelle der bundeswehr
oder der nato sagen also wenn das jetzt
so weitergeht und
jetzt noch also die regensaison sind der
macht stadt zukommt dann bleiben die im
wahrsten sinne des wortes immer stecken
so und das ist endlich mal jemand was
ganz anderes der mit atomwaffen
vorstellen kann und andere dinge der
auch schon angedroht ja so also darüber
nachzudenken wie man ihm etwas gibt kann
ich da doch das weist der toleranz immer
noch viel genauer darüber denken die
wahrscheinlich in der ukraine auch genau
nach
dass er vor sein volk treten kann und
sagen also ich habe ja und was für euch
raus geholt es geht immer wieder um
diesen er darf er muss irgendwie ohne
gesichtsverlust da rauskommen paul ohne
gesichtsverlust gibt es das überhaupt
noch wenn wir jetzt auch diese
zynische worte von la france sehen da
muss auch irgendwann der punkt kommen wo
der gesamten welt auch russland habe zu
das kann man nicht aufrechterhalten wie
will er da was kann man denn anbieten
ja ich glaube es gibt viele dramatische
aber auch interessante entwicklungen
neben dem drama und dem tod der hier
passiert in der ukraine sehen wir in
russland das heute das hat mein kollege
philipp jakob analysiert das erste mal
das staatsfernsehen den kriegt und sie
nennen ihn noch nicht krieg aber die
sogenannte operation
dort kritisiert und fragen aufwirft und
tatsächlich ist es ja so dass man ganz
unabhängig davon dass natürlich russland
auf dauer der ukraine massiv militärisch
überlegen ist darüber brauchen wir nicht
reden aber wenn man sich die jetzigen
zeitpunkt die dinge anschaut ist es
weiterhin so dass russland keine einzige
wirkliche großstadt eingenommen hat also
auch aktiv da haben wir den einsatz von
streubomben gesehen ist nicht
eingenommen von russland mario pohl ist
eingekreist und es gibt grausame kriege
aber weiterhin nicht eingenommen von
russland und das sei eine weitere
wichtige stadt nicht eingenommen und in
kiel wo schon seitdem ich hier an kaum
bin also bis in das zeitgefühl verloren
aber auch us dienste immer wieder gesagt
haben innerhalb von stunden tagen waren
auch immer könntet ihr fallen kiew steht
also militärisch sieht es momentan
nicht besonders gut aus für ihn jetzt
kann er natürlich sagen also für
wladimir putin er will noch brutaler
werden das würde bedeuten dass die
sanktion
vielleicht noch schärfer werden wir dann
auch in deutschland einen öl- und
gas-embargo erleben dass der druck auch
innenpolitisch für ihn schwieriger wird
oder er versucht eine lösung zu finden
in einer verhandlung da gab es erste
zeichen in die richtung das erste mal
dieses auch das lenski doch irgendwie
präsident bleiben könne wenn er denn
akzeptiere dass die ukraine neutral wird
dass sie nicht mehr nato ist dass teile
des bombers weg sind und so weiter und
so fort nur das sorgt dann gleichzeitig
für eine große problematik hier ich war
gestern nach dem interview noch länger
im präsidenten gebäude bei residenz gibt
und mit ihm weiter gesprochen beratern
gesprochen und natürlich wissen die das
momentan die situation in der ukraine so
ist das die mehrheit eine
hintersee lenz gesteht und die mehrheit
auch vereint ist in diesem patriotischen
blick auf das ganze und sagt nein wir
verteidigen uns wenn sie lenski jetzt
sagt in gesprächen ich bin zu allem
möglichen bereit und ich gebe mein land
her dann kann das bedeuten dass die
lenski nicht mehr lange präsident ist
und sozusagen hier eine innere die
stabilität passiert und das ist glaube
ich das ganz ganz schwierige im übrigen
wenn wir über kanäle sprechen zu
deutschland und zum regierungschef da
tut man es war so dass man telefoniert
aber der austausch an informationen
so wie ich das aus der ukraine erlebe da
ist man eigentlich ziemlich bedient was
deutschland angeht aber das nur am rande